Park yourself great steed for I need not
be there
please don't crash that's right [ __ ] I
got a Tesla [ __ ] that burns alright
y'all um I got a Tesla bad like I don't
know what to say you guys don't have to
want to get intense for the longest time
so you know you guys wanted to a quick
walk around in the car so I'm here to
just do it for you guys so real quick
we're just going to go through some of
the features of it because you know it's
baller like that
I barely know how to use this car yet so
bear with me because this is going to be
the ghettoest review and walkthrough of
a Tesla you've ever seen in your life
so real quick as you can see we got
wheels
these are tires it makes it go round
makes it go forward we got these side
view mirror things watch this [ __ ] as I
lock the car gangster if you want to
open up the car you can use key fob or
you can just do this have unlock on you
like that real quick with the quickness
watch want to open the door you see the
side view mirror dah
filled it up real quick excuse me boom
disappear gangster notes my little key
fob and how I control the Trump real
quick we're gonna do it with a quick
little double tap tap cool thing about
this trunk space though is because I do
have a lot of equipment and I do need to
carry things such as people Danielle can
you get in the truck real quick please
just to show them the size and you just
get inside there please I pay you so can
you do it
whatever Danielle doesn't leave a job
correctly this is where I'm gonna put
her and of course I'm not that mean of a
box laughs you got to give it some shape
and real quick just to show you guys
that if I do ever become a mop here and
still killer Lock them up real quick
don't even know I don't even be a touch
it punished
all right clap now let me show you
something else because this also is a
fully electric car the coolest thing
about this is not only do I have back
trunk space
I got trunk space that's [ __ ] front
trunk space BAM
later on when I have kids and they
misbehave in just like Danielle's I'm
gonna throw them right here next up I'm
gonna take you guys inside the car
because you guys have been so awesome
and I want to show you all how to use
this vehicle that even I don't know how
to use it
all right so now we are inside the car I
don't know too much about this vehicle
it doesn't function like a normal car
there's not a lot of analog buttons so
we're just going to go ahead and and you
know roll through it together
these are seats that were sitting in and
over here this is a screen apparently we
got the musica
we got the navigation that's navigation
for those of you who doesn't speak
Espinel I need to get the [ __ ] out but
then way I'm in the middle excuse me
sorry about this sir one of my favorite
features that I got and I've never had a
sunroof in the car before so this is a
pretty big deal when I touched this
magically I'm gonna just do it maybe
about like 25% or so 25% open maybe I
just want to open like a hundred percent
of the way how about you just open it up
like that Jeep ball is life maybe I just
want a little ventilation
off we go electric car I'm saving the
world that's what I'm telling myself
every day is that every day I Drive a
Tesla the earth distinctly she's like
you know what
thank you for having a zero-emission car
because you're not in meeting emitting
emitting no evil out into the earth so
here we go next up on the freeway we go
so this right here is called a
cul-de-sac notice the beautiful sights
of LA so we just hit the freeway and
this is the part that everybody freaks
out about on the Tesla is that autopilot
feature now when I first got into this
and the person who worked at Tesla
showed me this I freaked the [ __ ] out so
hopefully you guys will have that same
type of experience right here so with
the autopilot feature I'm going to hook
it on right now and I'm gonna see how
you guys feel about this if you trust it
or not here we go now we have autopilot
as I'm speaking to you and I'm trusting
that this cars gonna hit this curve very
well because if not I'm [ __ ] scared
gangster I'm still not used to this my
palms are sweating as [ __ ] this is the
110 so this is the reason why I wanted
to try to hear the most because the 110
is curvy as [ __ ] so the cool thing about
this is I actually set this to about 63
and if you are stuck in traffic and it's
going about like 10 to 15 miles an hour
it'll actually go to speed limit movie
starts going so I'm nervous as hell I'm
looking directly into if I hit this car
I'm not directly yeah
I must trust you Elon Musk like a relic
now oh my God my feet are sweaty this is
insane
technology blows my [ __ ] mind dude
the fact that I'm in a car that's
driving itself right now amazes me I
mean you talk about how lazy of a human
being I am this does not help at all
whatsoever cuz even driving is too
tiring now thought about before where we
were on all [ __ ] we were on horses we
were on carriages and now we had this
electric vehicle that drives itself
amazing now if I want to take this off I
could either Tahoe [ __ ] hold on see that
it says this car coming up on me Prius
yeah you a hybrid son you a full
electrics deal with it your mama's a
toasted [ __ ] if you want to switch
lanes sit the blinker
it'll sensible cars coming once it sit
in the lane click it off and there you
go oh [ __ ]
oh it's good it's good it's good I'm
bunking ok it's good it's good it's good
it's good yeah that's the cool feature
something that's really cool about
electric cars is the fact that
it's all talk I'll talk right as the tip
of the dick of this car I actually don't
know the technical term so that's what I
kind of made up myself so notice how
we're going at a normal speed because of
the torque
and I just wasted a couple of miles on
Mike but if you notice how quickly it
revs up how fast it goes amazing
Tesla freestyle uh all day I'm in my car
I spit bars I got a Tesla this is half
German Heat spaetzle all day I had to do
a foreign language cuz nothing rhymes
with Tesla
what's bet slow again cuz I use the word
again
goddammit you know grown up I didn't
have you know I wasn't really a rich kid
my parents when they came to this
country you know we didn't have a lot of
money we didn't have a lot of
extravagant things and to me like my mom
was telling me the other day she goes
you know your older brother is working
you know he has a great job you know
you're able to afford the things that
you want and she says like her job is
done and this is just a symbol of the
fact that you know you know I truly
believe that that's the American dream
it's not about having nice things but
it's that ability good to have choices
to do things that you want and it just
turns out that the things that I'm doing
gave me an opportunity to do something
like this and actually buy this car and
actually give my parents a new car too
as well I think that by far is probably
one of the the biggest accomplish that
I've done yet and yeah I just wanted to
share this moment with you guys and just
to show you guys that uh I don't know
like it's cool you know it's cool to be
able to afford things that I I want a
night and you guys know me as well on
this point to I don't really buy
anything that's why you guys always ask
why do you wear the same shirts why do
you wear the same clothes it's because I
don't buy clothes I don't buy a lot of
[ __ ] that I feel like I don't need and
you know growing up too in that type of
environment you feel like if you buy
things that don't really put a roof over
your head or food in your stomach you
think that you're being either selfish
or you
reminding that you don't need for me to
purchase this card it was actually a
very hard decision because you know to
me a car is just to get you from point A
to point B and you get something outside
of that was just a little bit of a hard
push for me but it's definitely
something that's well within something
that I can afford it I saved up you'll
be five years four so hope you guys
enjoyed the video and uh you all see me
in this car please don't rob me
Oh